hey guys what's up this is andrew for
join census.com
so i didn't make an update for quite
some time guys i'm so sorry about that
i was actually resigning from my job so
i can be
full-time here with you guys sharing the
knowledge about trading and making
updates every day
so today i want to make a massive one
guys a big
huge massive update because there are a
lot of things to say
on gamestop let's get into it
[Music]
so as usual we gonna start on the first
time frame guys i think it's the best
time frame to use when you do technical
analysis
for the reason that it's both used by
long-term investors
like institution clients and short-term
traders
so the signals that you can find here
are the
best signals for me so i'm gonna
maybe just recall what i was saying in
my last video so my last video was done
actually quite some time ago guys it was
done on the
posted on the 3rd of june but it was
done i think the day before
so gamestop was around 250 something
like this you know
we were here right in this area
so let me just remind you what i was
saying and then i'm gonna show you
my different scenarios so for now forget
about that guys
we're gonna see this very soon all right
let's keep it like this
so here guys you can go and check this
video guys
i was basically telling you that we are
bullish we were in this
five waves development so one two three
four five
and we were in the fourth wave so i was
telling you guys we are waiting for the
fifth wave that's the reason why i was
bullish i gave you a target of 300
we went actually slightly above i mean
50 points
higher but it was this day was very
interesting that i'm gonna come to this
we basically blew the 300 level on the
upside
but came back right away so here
basically there was a lot of
bearish signals i'm gonna go through
this
i'm sorry guys i didn't give you the
signals when they were happening
but i told you that we're going to
correct 220 which we did
so i'm going to explain exactly what i
mean by various signals and you're going
to see that
each time these corrections happen so we
can expect those corrections to happen
on the larger degree
wave counting and i have here one here
is the two you see
so i'm not sure the two is here here
we're gonna discuss this very soon and
i'm gonna give you what you
here for guys uh which is actually how
to time
and how to know when the third wave is
gonna start
i'm going to go to this very soon but
first let me
here finish the analysis on the shorter
term
so basically this fifth wave was
expected the second wave here was
expected as well
and i was telling you that here you can
use a training star plus using the
moving averages
so once again i just want to show you
guys how just worked here
very well so basically i was telling you
the
50 moving average on the hourly
timeframe is a very
good support level so you can see one
reaction here
one reaction here so two three
four five and here guys look at what
happened
it's just you know i can't be here
always with you maybe i'm going to do
some
live updates very soon now that i have
resigned from my position but once again
you know when you resign
from a position like mine it takes time
you know you need to prepare
what they call the hanover which is
basically showing everybody what you
were doing
how to use a spreadsheet how to work in
your environment
and basically do what you were doing and
this takes like one week or two
so i'm not gonna be free right away but
very soon guys i'm gonna be here
every day with you and here look we
broke
this uh 50 moving average and then as
usual
we are retesting it so here we have your
signal let's check on the first time
frame
on the first time frame the signal was
too late you see so that's why when you
do short term
the fourth time frame is a bit lagging
too much it can't
it doesn't give you the retest you need
to enter your trade but the hourly time
frame gives you your retest
here it's broken confirmed and then here
we tested and from then we went
lower so this was here guys once again
a very good signal to use and i was
telling you guys this
all the way up i was telling you don't
sell if you don't have
your bearish signal so this is one of
them but let me show you all the other
signals that we had
here so something that you guys know i
like to use
for those who are watching my videos for
some time i very often come back to this
because this is for me a very precious
indicator
which is divergences so let me show you
quickly what are divergences
so here we are going to focus on the
classic one which is the regular
divergence
in the bearish mode so basically the
price action is here in blue
and you can use any momentum indicator
stochastic rsi
or macd i like to use it with macd but
it's working with all of them
and basically the market is making new
high so you can see here we're making
new highs one high here second high here
and in the same time
the momentum indicator is giving you a
bearish signal because
you can see that the momentum is going
down it's making
lower highs which means that the market
is out of steam
which means that the bears are gaining
confidence and that the bulls
are not able to take ground as much as
they used to
the proceeding moves up so let me show
you exactly how it looks
here so basically you just connect the
highs that you have
so one high second high third high
and look at the macd in the same time
guys so the magnet during the same time
was just doing lower highs so you have
the market making higher highs and the
macd
making lower highs all right so this
means that the market
is out of steam this means that the move
down
is to come so you had this signal
actually
here already and you can see it's not
that easy to use but you need to
associate those with the other
indicators that you are using
because here one two you already had the
divergence
here you can see on the 2nd of june here
it was
already a divergence and still the
market got rejected but
managed to make a new high in a very
sharp way
but look what happened guys it didn't
last it didn't last even one hour when i
go
on the first time frame you don't even
see this strong move up i mean
the candle is just a doji candle all
right it's like we go
very strongly up and then we get
rejected all the buyers
here they got stuck guys they lost money
and so bears took confidence and from
here this is a very strong
reversal candle that associated to what
was happening before
you knew that here you could expect some
correction
to start one more thing guys is that
it's interesting to see that
here we had a kind of weird phenomenon
that happens sometimes
let me show you guys this so in this
fifth wave actually you
you don't find five waves you know one
two three
four and you you have five waves but the
fifth wave is truncated all right
so it happens sometimes you know it's
just bears that
suddenly managed to beat the boots so
here the bulls
basically they were not strong enough to
hold against
all the the sellers probably hedge funds
mostly
and yeah this is the kind of things that
can happen sometimes so here i have an
incomplete wave counting
in my fixed wave so we have a truncated
fifth wave which is something
that can happen so it's not easy to
trade but once again guys we had the
bearish divergence
we still know we are in the fifth wave
and we knew that this
first wave that is here guys let me take
a step back
needed to correct at some points so the
higher we go
the better it is guys the better it is
because once again let me show you
something that is very interesting
i have so many things i want to show you
guys here but we're going to do them one
by one
here the reason why it's good to go
higher is because i told you guys that
if you are not comfortable with strength
lines i like to use streamlines that's
why i found the 220 level all right
that's why i told you for already like i
was telling you for already more than
two weeks
that we're gonna connect to the 220
level we went to 207 something like this
but you can see that on four hours time
frame the 220 level is holding very well
it's not broken here it's tested here we
close below
but here we manage to close above so you
don't have two consecutive candles
trading below this level
so this level is holding for now this
level is very strong
i'm gonna show you the different
scenarios uh it's there are some
scenarios
where we trade below this level but
don't worry guys in all of these
scenarios we finally
tread much higher i'm gonna come to this
very very soon but here let me just
show you how to use fibs some of you
were asking me to
to show you how to use fibs so i think
it's interesting i'll show you now
so you measure the first wave now you
know this wave is complete you
knew it already for some time you knew
it when we broke the 50 period moving
average on the hourly time frame you
knew
already all the it's working as well
with the 20 period moving average on the
first time frame
the blue one that is here you can see
it's supporting the price the same way
here it's
broken retested and then we go lower so
here you knew
but actually you could know even here
after this dodgy candle guys when you
have so strong
this kind of strong moves up and all the
buyers get caught here
it's not good all right so you measure
the wave and then you apply
the fibonacci ratios so once again
fibonacci is a method based um
golden number that is a number that you
can find everywhere in everything that
is growing you can find any plants you
can find
anything that follows a growing process
so markets is one of these things and so
here when you measure this wave
then you're usually retracing i'm
actually right now guys making a full
course that i'm gonna
share with you where it's gonna be
comprehensive
training where i explain all the methods
that work for me
i'm gonna explain to you guys how to use
them exactly in
in which situations so that's why i
resigned from my job this
is gonna take me a lot of time to do but
i'm already doing it
and you're gonna see that in this course
the method i'm gonna give you guys to
enter with fibs
uh some people they like to buy here and
here i mean the 38.2 i don't like to buy
this level sometimes you we
be retracing here but most of the time
we will trace him to the 50 or 61.8
percent retracement so here i would be a
buyer at 240
and at 215 using only fibs without using
trend lines that require
some more skills but if you even if you
are not able to
draw efficient trend lines you can still
use fibs
which is much easier to do and that is
working very well
as well so here buyer at 240 buyer 215
we're gonna see with trend lines that
here we have a strong support as well
and then in the fibs method below the
1.786
retracement basically the scenario is of
the table so if you are just using fibs
in a bullish market you should stop lost
your position here below
the 180 level so this is giving you
some levels beyond which the bullish
scenario
is of the table just using fibs method
so in my scenarios we are not getting
there don't worry but this is just
something that you can keep in mind
all right so here i'm done with fibs so
once again now we
are we completed this fixed wave we saw
that we had
some signals like the bearish divergence
let me show you again quickly
this regular bearish divergence that was
telling you that the first wave is gonna
be complete soon so now what are our
different scenarios
so let me show you again you know you
just type elliot wave on google you go
to the third
link and you find the pdf this is the
boot guys that i read
that is very complicated that is
basically explaining to you guys
everything about the different wave
formations
how they work together and what i want
to bring you to here
for now is the corrective waves so i'm
going to show you guys that basically
you we have
here three scenarios actually mostly two
scenarios
so by the way i actually already did
some
training about that guys just click on
the link in the description of this
video
and you're gonna receive this free
training that i've already made that is
around one or two hours
where i explain in a very basic way all
this theory that is very complicated
and i think that is very interesting for
you guys to start getting familiar with
illiot
waves theory and basically here
corrective
processes come in two styles sharp
corrections angles deeply against the
larger trend
sideways corrections so basically this
is where i wanted to bring you guys and
we can have a zigzag
or we can have a flat we can also have
triangles but
triangles very rarely occur in second
waves so here we either gonna have a
zigzag
or a flat now this correction was
sharp enough to be done so the question
we're having here so
the first question that you guys having
is this correction complete or not
so let me just start to label
this with you so a b
c so this could be our zigzag
this could be a complete correction once
again the c
wave itself is in five waves as you can
see
in the book that i just showed you i'm
not gonna go through this
here with you again one two three four
five
so this is a c wave so this abc
correction could be complete
and one of the scenarios i'm giving you
here my first scenario
which is basically the one that i'm
calling for two or three weeks guys
you can go and check my videos once
again i told you we're going to go to
300
we went slightly above but we didn't
really close above on the four hours
time frame
and then i told you we're going to
correct 220 and then start the third
wave
so this is one of the scenarios now
another thing that is interesting to
take into account
is that you can see that this wave lasts
from the 11th of may
to the 8th of june so basically one
month so when you have
one month move up usually even if the
correction is sharp enough in spot to me
maybe we're gonna consolidate here a bit
more so we have two different
uh possibilities from here either this
is just
a first move and then we're gonna do
basically another zigzag
that is just a bit longer so something
like this
and then we could go here or even here
we could do a flat then
you know we can do basically i'm gonna
give you the two scenarios in the same
time either we do a flat
something like this or we do a zigzag so
depending on how
high the b wave is going it's gonna
impact uh the c wave as well
all right the higher the b wave is going
the less likely it is that the c
wave is actually going below wave a so
we're gonna have
a look at how this b wave is developing
but
here uh probably on monday we're gonna
be a bit consolidating maybe at the
beginning of the session and then
probably
go strongly higher and then this is when
you're gonna have two different
scenarios either we already starting the
third wave
or we actually doing an abc so once
again first scenario is this one that
you have in here
second one is for example this one sorry
second one is this one so we're gonna
analyze what is happening here
if the first scenario plays out so once
again the first scenario is gonna be
like this
so if the first scenario plays out guys
it's easy to actually
see because we're gonna have a one
two and then three all right
four and five and here
you can see that the two scenarios
they're both gonna do the same thing
in any case i think we're gonna trade
higher on monday with some impulsive
moves
but we need to pay attention is this
first wave in five waves or not
on the for example five minutes time
frame uh if here you have five waves
this is probably meaning that this is a
one two
three four five because then the one is
motive on the other hand if here we have
only three waves
then this move is corrective so pay
attention of
if you see something like this then
probably this is motive and here we're
gonna have zigzag and then one two three
four five
and here if you have something that is
looking more
like this
then it means that probably this is just
an abc and that here we're gonna have a
one two three four five
getting maybe going maybe to the 195
level
why 195 because it's the maximum of the
b wave here
so i prefer to use trend lines but once
again if you use fibs
you can see that this is working well as
well using fibs
show you that all the area that is above
the 180 level
is a buying area alright guys so let me
just sum up here
the information i was giving to you so
basically i think
that this correction is either done or
not we're probably going to have some
moves up on monday for me the levels to
buy are everything between 220
and 195. if we trade below 195
i would start to be a bit careful but
you know i don't want to trade too long
below this level i certainly don't want
to see
a closing daily candle below the 195
level
but once again let me remind you guys
look this is amc so i'm going to come to
amc very soon
but just to remind you guys you know so
the amc is here so gamestop just did the
first wave
you know just to compare guys luke amc
is one step ahead
gamestop just finished its its first
wave after this huge breakout
and is now retracing and doing the
second wave amc second wave
was very deep in terms of retracement
so i think it's interesting to see that
we went to the
98.6 retracement level that was a bit
tricky this is not usual but we need to
keep in mind that gamestop can have the
same behavior
all right so if we have the same
behavior this means that gamestop would
go to the 180
level roughly so we might go there very
you know a very short period of time so
yeah
just to keep in mind that this scenario
is not making
my bullish scenario weaker i mean maybe
slightly weaker but still
very very achievable and once again i'm
not sure if we're gonna consolidate
here or not but in both cases the third
wave is gonna start
and pay attention in the number of waves
it moves up if you have five waves this
is
motive if you have three waves this is
corrective so this is one
method that you need to associate with
all the other indicators that you are
using we don't like to see divergences i
don't have
any bearish divergence on the larger
time frame so this is a very good to me
and now i want to bring you guys to the
financial
data that is very interesting to have a
look at
so this is my dashboard guys alright so
we are here on gamestop so first let me
maybe show you guys
the option open interest so once again
for those who are watching my video for
the first time i'm here making
updates often as i can about the uh
synthetic short interest that
we have on the option market i can hear
a lot of different things
regarding this option uh market but
i'm an option trader i mean i was
because i am resigning
so i know how to use this data so
basically you take the open interest
you multiply it by 100 this is the
formula
and you multiply it by the delta and of
course
the spot price and this is giving you
synthetic short exposure
and once again to get the delta i just
use black shells formula i do this
for all the maturity so you can see i
put my maturities here
and uh the black shells formula is this
one all right
so it's just basic black shorts formula
and
by doing this you are having the real
exposure and you can have this
for every maturity and every strike and
it's very interesting to see that for
gamestop guys as i'm telling you all the
time
look what we're having on the 800 strike
guys even for amc we didn't have
such a big exposure here and it's very
interesting to see that this exposure
guys is coming
mostly from the 18th of june uh sorry
let me
on amc it's coming from june on gamestop
let me show you
where it's coming from this 800 so we're
having 3.5 million shares
and coming mostly from here guys as you
can see right
mostly from here so so this is july
all right this is the july maturities
it's mostly coming from the july
maturity guys
which is very soon so i expect for this
reason because the gamma
this is creating some gamma on the
upside and it's the this gamma that is
creating
the beginning of the squeeze even if
it's not a real squeeze like i said
already for amc
because the real squeeze is much sharper
for now we're just having a healthy
bullish development on amc on gamestop
of course as well
and in this bullish development what is
creating the momentum
for now it's the uh option interest that
we're having on those
very out of the money strikes that are
priced on a very high velocity guys look
at this
380 percent it's
very very big and this is what market
makers needs to use
to price those collapsions if they don't
want to get destroyed by the price
action moving higher
and one other very interesting
information is here that for
example the delta is the probability of
finishing in the money so you can see
that the delta of the 800 strike
on the july maturity is 18 guys 18
so this means there is 18 chance
according to the market makers models
that we finished above 800
in one month for me it's more something
closer to
50 all right but this is what
the option market is showing us so this
is of course
very bullish and when i see this i know
that if the price action starts to go
higher so
in the third wave typically we're gonna
have very strong moves up
all right another very interesting
information is here i compute
since i started my channel guys so in
november i'm recording uh
this very important data which is the
equity flow that selling number of
shares
the short interest 12 million shares
short interest guys
so this is a lot it's around 20
of regulations interest so of course
here i don't take into account the naked
shorts
i know they are in this market i know
they are but
you can't find them anywhere and what is
interesting is to see if this data which
is
good data is growing or not for now you
can see that it's stable so of course
the shots
have not covered and the synthetic shot
that i
get using the information i get on the
option market is right now ten percent
guys all right
gamestop is at 230 we're having 10
imagine gamestop is going to 800
we're getting 23 percent of short
interest 10 billion usd so this is
the money market makers need the
position the market makers need to buy
around 9 billion us dollars they need to
buy this this is the money that people
who have collapsions
the exposure that they're having so
market makers if they don't want to be
left short they need to buy in this
market
so this is the reason why it's so
bullish so just let me come back here so
the short interest is stable 12 million
shares
uh compared to the 8 14 of may data but
once again this data is you know almost
two weeks old so i'm wondering what it
is right now
but for now it's stable what i don't
want to see is here a drop i don't want
to see a drop in volatility as well
so this is january 23 but in the
short-term volatility if you see a drop
here
it means market makers are not scared
anymore and they need to be scared
for this uh squeeze to happen i mean
this healthy voice development
to 800 to happen which is not the
squeeze
yet the squeeze will come after this
when market makers hedge funds are gonna
increase their short positions and then
they can get squeezed
so that's it for me guys i hope you
enjoyed this update it was a bit longer
than usual because i had a lot of things
to tell you
so we are bullish everything is fine for
me we can
uh go as low as 180 and my bullish
scenario is still gonna be my preferred
scenario
i think we can consolidate maybe one or
two more days maybe one more or two
weeks this is possible as well so this
is in this environment we need
to pay attention to how many waves we
have in the
moves up this is how we can guess
if we are now developing in the third
wave or if we are still correcting in
the second wave
so if you enjoyed this video guys please
don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore i see you
guys